unfortunately this story is not changing
and we are seeing new evidence that
America's coronavirus crisis is getting
worse 41 states report a growing number
of new cases Pennsylvania's governor's
ordering nightclubs and bars to close
statewide after a jump in infections
their health officials say the outbreak
in Los Angeles has hit an alarming and
dangerous phase and there's a record
number of kovat hospitalizations across
the United States Anthony we're also
seeing more pushback over wearing masks
in public from those who insist on it
and others who say they don't want any
face coverings or leave national
correspondent David Beck know is in
Miami David Florida just topped 300,000
total cases are the hospital's they're
able to keep up well Anthony take
miami-dade County for example the
hottest of hot spots here in South
Florida
the most populated county in the state
they have reached their traditional ICU
capacity so what are they doing now
they're setting up overflow beds getting
them ready now the good news is they had
less people with Kovac being admitted to
the ICU you got to look for the good
news here but the concern is even the
extra beds that they're setting up are
not going to be enough moving forward
which beds kovat beds which beds can we
create safe isolation for that's dr.
Nicholas Timaeus president of medical
staff here at Jackson Health System in
Miami he says it may be too late to
avoid bed shortages we have gridlock and
we won't be able to take patients in
they'll just be stacking in the ers and
got tested yesterday for code 19 and the
results came back positive
Oklahoma's governor Kevin state became
the first governor to test positive for
the virus on Wednesday the same day his
state broke its single day record for
new cases from home in quarantine he
says he's not thinking at all about
issuing a statewide mask mandate State
hosted president Trump's rally in Tulsa
last month where he was seen not wearing
a mask it was a different story in
Alabama that state's governor kiv says
masks are now mandatory effective today
increased cases every day are still
occurring and we are almost to the point
[Music]
in the absence of a federal mask mandate
some national chains like Starbucks
request all customers wear masks
yesterday Walmart America's largest
retailer announced a mask mandate at all
of its more than 5,000 stores the
nation's largest supermarket chain
Kroger followed suit CBS News chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook
there's been mixed messaging about the
need to wear face masks I think that the
default on a national level should be to
wear a face mask you can't let your
guard down not even one time it takes
that one slip-up so not wear your mask
do not wash your hands
Michelle Simon says she her husband John
place and their four children all tested
positive for corona virus she says her
21 year old son likely brought the virus
home after getting together with some
friends who relaxed about wearing masks
her husband John is now on a ventilator
I know your 21 year old son feels a lot
of guilt what do you tell him you know I
mean his dad loves him very much we all
love him it's not that were claiming him
we could have caught it anywhere his dad
could have got it anywhere else she's
got to pull through I mean there's no
other way cuz I'm not gonna tell his
six-year-old daughter that her daddy's
not coming over she's not gonna happen
this is the 19th morning that John
places on the ICU fighting for his life
you know Florida remains a state where
the governor refuses to institute a
national mandate for masks statewide but
north of here overnight in Georgia the
governor actually passed a law that
overturns all local ordinances mandating
masks including in cities like Atlanta
and Savannah and I want to read you a
tweet from the mayor of Savannah he
tweeted last night it's officially
official governor Kemp does not give a
damn about us every man and woman for
himself herself ignore the science and
survived the best you can Tony it's
dispiriting to see public health policy
become a political battle but there you
have it David thank you very much of a
unique way of bringing it home for us